even a great movie can be ruined by a
bad ending it's arguably the hardest and
most important part to get right
continuity errors and awkward dialogue
might be forgiven but a movies ending
sticks with the audience long after the
credits roll thankfully that's what
alternate endings are for check out
these famous films with awesome
alternate endings but watch out for
spoilers Heather's in the 1988 black
comedy Heather's Veronica played by
Winona Ryder learns a lesson about the
high cost of popularity after she joins
a clique of girls all named Heather at
her school she also becomes romantically
involved with the new student JD played
by Christian Slater who is determined to
shake up the social status quo in some
very unexpected ways like with bombs in
the theatrical ending after JD's bomb
explodes
Veronica walks into the school where she
encounters Heather Duke Veronica takes
away Heather's red scrunchie and tells
her Heather my love there's a new
sheriff in town then she catches up to
her old friend Martha dumptruck gunstock
and the film ends on a hopeful note
several other endings - Heather's were
scrapped along the way the original
ending was the bomb was strapped to me
and I give this amazing speech in the
best alternate version writer Daniel
waters gives Martha dumb stock the last
laugh when Veronica tries to rekindle
their friendship
Martha stabs her in the chest calling
her Heather as she dies Veronica
protests that her name isn't Heather but
Martha ignores her getting up from her
wheelchair and triumphantly walking away
from the friends that betrayed her ouch
the butterfly effect in the 2004
psychological thriller at the butterfly
effect 20-year old Evan discovers his
frequent headaches and blackouts are
actually a manifestation of his ability
to travel back in time
Evan uses his childhood journals to go
back and change traumatic experiences
for himself and his friends however he
soon learns that even small and
seemingly positive changes can
drastically affect the future and not
always in a good way in the theatrical
ending Evan travels back to the day he
met his four
Kaleigh and changes things so they never
meet and become neighbors when evan
returns to the future he's relieved to
see that this change has made things
better for the lives of his friends he
burns his journals thereby preventing
himself from ever altering the timeline
again the alternate ending found on the
director's cut DVD is much darker than
the original on the brink of madness
evan travels back in time strangling
himself in the womb with his own
umbilical cord to prevent his own birth
for a movie that offers so much to think
about this ending is definitely the more
thought-provoking one first blood in the
1982 action film first blood Vietnam
veteran John Rambo drifts through
Washington State where he has a run-in
with an intolerant sheriff after the
former Green Beret refuses to be pushed
around by the authoritarian cop
Rambo finds himself fighting for his
life as he tries to escape the small
town and invade the lawmen and his
lackeys at the end
Rambo corners and wounds the sheriff
preparing to kill him however his former
commander Colonel Sam Troutman arrives
in time to stop John from doing the deed
and Rambo breaks down recounting his
traumatic experiences during the war and
surrendering to Troutman it's not
necessarily a bad ending but it was a
little unsatisfying and it left the door
open for several mediocre sequels the
original ending - first blood keeps much
closer to David morals 1972 novel Rambo
still has his tearful breakdown but he
decides that the events of Vietnam have
made his life all but pointless as he
can't live normally in society anymore
Rambo gives the colonel his gun
when Troutman can't do it
rainbow grabs his arm causing the gun to
go off given what we know of rainbows
character this finale seems like a more
fitting and realistic way for him to go
out pretty and pink John Hughes 1986
cult classic pretty and pink features
geeky high schoolers Andy and her best
friend
ducky ducky is madly in love with Andy
but she begins dating the popular blame
triggering a bitter argument with ducky
later plains friend Steph teases him
about Andy causing Blaine to avoid her
and lie about his prom plans undeterred
Andy goes to the prom alone but she
still has a chance to find true love at
the prom and and ducky make up and head
for the dance floor after telling Steph
what he thinks of him Blaine
congratulate ducky and tells Andy how he
feels about her kissing her on the cheek
and walking out
[Music]
ducky puts his own feelings aside and
encourages Andy to follow him Andy and
Blaine kiss in the parking lot
ducky dances with a cute girl and they
all live happily ever after
it's all very romantic if you're a 13
year old girl test audiences as it turns
out didn't like the original ending
which had Andy choose ducky over plain
pretty and pink should have been about
two geeks finding love but the revised
ending turns into a formulaic teen fairy
tale except Blaine is no Prince Charming
hey let's go upstairs huh jon cryer may
be famous for that dance in the record
store but the scene where ducky sits in
his room listening to Morrissey is the
most honest performance of teenage
heartbreak ever filmed Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world in Edgar rates 2010 action
comedy Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
slacker musician Scott Pilgrim flounders
his way through an unsatisfying life
he's a bassist and a struggling Garage
Band he has no plans for the future and
his girlfriend knives Chow is a clingy
17 year old high school student when
Scott meets Ramona he immediately
becomes infatuated with her but he must
defeat her seven evil exes in order to
win her heart the ending used for the
theatrical release was actually supposed
to be the movies alternate ending it was
shot after the original one had been
filmed in order to match the ending of
the Scott Pilgrim graphic novels after
helping Scott defeat Ramona's final evil
ex knives tells Scott that she's come to
terms with their breakup and understands
that their relationship is over although
she swore to win him back
knives gives her blessing for Scott to
pursue his new romance with Ramona in
the film's original ending Scott
realizes that he still has feelings for
knives your hair is getting really
shaggy it is
I like it
you do the cup will rekindle their
romance over a videogame and Ramona
realizes that she doesn't need to be in
a relationship or constantly reinventing
herself to be happy staying healthy and
mature decision making in a movie is
like seeing a unicorn in the wild which
is why we love this ending die hard with
a vengeance in 1995's die hard with a
vengeance terrorists
Simon Gruber has taken all of New York
City hostage in order to steal a
boatload of gold and to get revenge on
lieutenant John McClane for the death of
his brother Hans with the help of Harlem
shopkeepers Zeus Carver McClane deals
with the bomb threats in bank heists as
he pursues Gruber and his lackeys across
the five boroughs at the film's climax
McClane follows Gruber to a hideout in
Quebec most of the bad guys are quickly
rounded up but Gruber and his girlfriend
attempt to escape in a helicopter
McClane manages to get the best of them
it's a typical action film finale
unrealistic full of questionable physics
and made to showcase a big explosion
because in an alternate ending Gruber
escapes with the gold while McClane
takes the blame for the terrorists trail
of destruction
the NYPD kicks McClane off the force but
he goes rogue and tracks down Simon
Gruber himself how are my friends and
the NYPD well I was fired from the NYPD
cops trying to save my pension oh I'm
sorry to hear that
he corners the villain forcing him to
play a game of McClane says with riddles
and a rocket launcher thrown in for fun
after a few suspenseful rounds Gruber
loses taking an RPG to the chest this
more realistic ending is miles better
than the theatrical version sometimes a
small boom is even more satisfying than
a big one
[Music]